[Music]
all about acknowledging your
shortcomings in life a lot of people
talk about triple down on your strengths
triple down on your strengths and don't
worry about your shortcomings that's a
whole new thing I'm hearing right now
maybe it's not new best new to me
because I'm not out there really
listening to all this stuff that's the
quickest way to never grow to never grow
if you sit there and have that mentality
of triple down on what you're good at
you're never going to grow you're always
going to stay the same either you're
getting better you're getting worse so
one thing that helped me out a lot when
I was growing up was people always asked
me how do you build mental toughness
mental toughness well I had these
classes out here a class on mental
toughness positive thinking
visualization all these different
techniques mental toughness is a
lifestyle it's something that you live
every single day of your life when I was
growing up I was a lazy kid I was a lazy
kid never goes how did you get to where
you're at today how did you get to where
you're running 200 miles at one time in
39 hours being so disciplined
it started off honestly with recognizing
that my bedroom was dirty
my bed wasn't made I lived a sloppy life
so I took very small increments in my
life I started making my bath started
cleaning my room there were dishes in
the sink it started off with doing small
house chores I saw that the yard needs
to be mowed so instead of being told you
need to be mowed I would mow it I
started doing things coming outside of
my lazy ways to become better and
through a period of time your brain
doesn't like it but it starts to realize
this is a new way of thinking we are now
doing things that we aren't comfortable
doing we are doing things that we don't
want to do so the brain starts to slowly
grow and let's say you don't like to get
up early in the morning time to go run I
hated it I still hate it you do that
you live uncomfortable to gain growth
you have to have friction in your life
to gain growth and the only way to do
that is to make yourself uncomfortable
and get to the point where instead of
running from the things you don't want
to do you actually face them and start
to gain more and more growth in your
life so that's I approach all those
things self-talk for me has been the
biggest thing in my life a lot of us
have a dialogue that is crap it's a
crappy dialogue we live in a world right
now that is very external everything is
very on the surface superficial
everything and what we're telling
ourselves is what we see on TV is where
we see on instagrams we see on Facebook
and we're telling ourselves stuff that
doesn't really penetrate to our core to
the inside of our soul so our self-talk
is like what am I gonna wear today how
am I gonna look today I need to act this
way today because this way is cool my
self-talk became something that actually
made me better and I had a whole bunch
of negative things in my life and to get
to the self-talk portion of it first
you have to quiet all of the phones and
social media and all the negativity of
the world to get to even hear your own
self have a self-talk you can't have
self-talk if you're hearing someone
else's dialogue and what they're putting
out on social media how they want you to
act how they want you to dress how they
want you to talk everything out there is
your trying to keep up with somebody
you're not trying to find your own self
so you have to clear away all the crap
and how you clear away the crap to even
get to yourself talk is you have to get
all of the noise of all the crap of the
world out of your head so I call it
going to a dark place you have to get
the noise out quiet your mind down get
all the static out before you can even
have a real conversation with yourself
and the in that self-talk a lot of times
it's very negative because of all the
stuff we see on TV all the stuff we see
on so
the media you have to create a positive
dialogue there's something I do that I
have a demonstration and I make somebody
very strong and I can make him very weak
within three seconds
I put self-talk I put my own voice in
their subconscious and I do something to
them
that makes them very weak and they
wonder how in the world do you do this I
do it because I'm putting my own
dialogue in your head I'm telling a
person that you're insecure I'm telling
a person that's you're weak and I'm able
to make this person almost they have no
strength and then I give it right back
to them and all day long we are feeding
ourselves the wrong self-talk it's
negative self-talk so all day long I'm
putting the positive self-talk in my
subconscious I'm making sure that I'm
walking around all day long giving
myself to proper fuel to attack the
world that's why I work out hard every
day I work out hard every day because I
know the first thing in the morning what
I do is I clean my room I clean my house
I go for a run I work out I want to win
the war in the morning because the
second I leave my house
the second you look at your phone the
second you turn the TV on you're in a
battle all this negativity is coming at
you but if you're able to fuel yourself
in the morning win the war in the
morning so you have the strength to face
what you're going to face in the world
the world's going to come at you with
left's and rights you have to have the
right kind of mentality and that starts
by not hitting the snooze button it
starts by waking up no you don't want to
do it but that gives you the strength
because you did it if you do it if you
do something you don't want to do every
morning you're ready giving yourself to
proper self-talk you're already giving
yourself to proper dialogue to attack
that people that don't like you to
attack your insecurities to attack what
the world is going to give you so
self-talk comes from belief in yourself
if you give yourself
self-talk positive self-talk but you
don't believe it it's not going to come
true you have to put the work behind
what you're saying and believe what
you're saying yourself for that
self-talk to become a reality in your
subconscious so no matter what anybody
says to you no matter what you hear you
know the truth and you're living through
the truth and no one can
no one can penetrate that no one so one
thing I developed in my life going
through hard times is a cookie jar the
cookie jar is all of us have a story
we've all overcome so many things in our
lives but we forget them and in a lot of
times we don't spend enough time like
reflecting back in our lives realizing
how great we truly are we go through
something we put it back and we go on in
life is going to always challenge us
always challenges and during that
challenge the moment we panic we forget
who we truly are that cookie jar that I
designed for my brain is something that
in that one second of panic we lose our
mind and we also lose how far we've come
in life you take that one second
go through your cookie jar grab
something in your mind look at it read
it open it up oh I was in three hell
weeks I graduated two of them that's a
cookie it remind yourself just how hard
you are and it puts you right back into
the right frame of mind to overcome
whatever's in front of you and usually
whatever's in front of you isn't as big
as you make it out to be we start to
make these very small things enormous
because we allow our minds to take
control and go away from us we have to
regain control of our mind and that's
what the cookie jar is it's getting
wreak it's gaining control of a
situation that isn't that big most
situations in life aren't that big and
if they are that big usually we can find
the strength to handle them just do
having the right mental process the 40%
rule something that I designed also when
I was growing up I now have 300 most
doing
pounds and I lost all the weight to
become a Navy SEAL I realized that I
could have lived the rest of my life
being a 300 pound person never knowing
what was truly inside of me I couldn't
have been happy with that person I was
living at about 40% maybe not even 40%
so in life like a car a car a lot of
cars have governors on them a governor
is something where let's say the
speedometer says I hunt 30 miles an hour
you put a governor on a car it may only
go 91 miles an hour because that
governor stops that car from going 130
we do the same thing to our brain when
our brain starts to go through suffering
when our brain starts to go through pain
or starts to go through insecurities
when we start to feel uncomfortable with
ourself our brain gives us a way out and
that way out is usually quitting or
taking the easier route if we're able to
look at ourselves and face whatever
we're running from you start to gain
more percent on top of that 40 you start
to realize okay you sort of slowly take
that governor off your brain we can do a
lot more than we think like at work a
lot of us have a horrible mentality at
work we go to work we put all these
negative things in our brains and it
starts to cap our potential we cap our
potential by saying we were given 100%
no one's really given a hundred percent
usually you're given 40 percent because
that governor stopping you you feel pain
you feel suffering you feel discomfort
you stop right there everybody has a
wall in their mind it's a wall and it
stops us from going further most walls
have a door or a window you have to find
that you have to have the courage to
find that and once you open that door or
that window you realize how much further
you can go and you can continue hitting
doors in windows along this journey but
you have to have the courage to open
them up to get to that hundred percent
so it's all about having the courage and
real
that we have a governor we have to push
past that governor in pastor ol mind
games
[Music]